the scp foundation a secret organization
dedicated to containing and cataloging
the supernatural in all its forms have
encountered some terrifying things but
none were scarier than what they found
behind a limestone cave in joppa indiana
an entity known as scp-2930
that may be the embodiment of death
itself the foundation sent a team to
explore through the cave and found an
exact copy of our own universe on the
other side with one key difference
literally everything had dropped dead at
the exact same moment the level of death
was so totally incomplete there wasn't
even any rotting because the necessary
bacteria had all died too in the end the
team made a horrifying discovery their
own bodies and one of them was rotten
this could only mean one thing their
equivalents in another dimension must
have brought death here the living team
locked themselves in and used an
explosive to commit suicide they feared
that if they ever came back to our world
they'd bring the death with them and
we'd suffer the same fate